in this video you're going to learn how
to work with composition of functions
when you're given a table we're going to
go through five examples together so
let's dive in so we're given this table
here and we're trying to figure out like
what is g of f of one so just a quick
note about the notation you'll see it
written like this like f of G of X and
the way I like to write it is in this
notation right here F of G of X because
what you're doing is you're working from
the inside out so the way functions work
is whatever is in the parentheses that's
like your input that goes into the
function that's like your x value and
what comes out is this G of X that's
like the the yvalue or the answer you
would then take that yalue that's like
the new input in the F function and so
basically what you're doing it's like a
double substitution so let's look at
some examples and you'll get a feel for
how this works so when we see G of f of
one we're actually working from right to
left or the way I like to think of it as
G of f of one working from the inside
out like you learned when you did the
PEMDAS or the order of operations so
we'd say if one is our input in our F
function so okay we have here our x
value our input is one the output or the
Y value for our F function is going to
be zero so that means that this quantity
here is zero and now that becomes the
input in our G function so we say okay
when X is zero we go over to our G
function oh the output is
ne1 and we solved it so it's really like
again a double substitution you're
you're solving and then you're taking
that answer putting into the next
function and you're solving so let's go
to number two let's take a look at this
one so we have G of f of1 so again
another way to think about this is
writing it in a slightly different
notation G of f of1 we start from the
inside and we work our way out so we say
okay if negative 1 is our input in our F
function okay X is ne-1 and then the
output for our functions going to be two
so this whole quantity is two and now
you can see that that output becomes the
input and our next function our G
function so we go over here to xal 2 and
our G function the output would be three
so that means that this whole thing here
now is equal to three so it's kind of
like two steps just a quick refresher
before we do the next problem see if you
have a function like this F ofx = 2x -1
if I say what's F of four see whatever
is in parentheses that goes in for X on
the right so this would be 2 * 4 - 1
which is 7 but in this case they've done
all that work for us in the table they
don't give us the actual equation they
just give us the inputs and the outputs
for the F function and the g function so
let's look at number three now so maybe
you can try this one if you're getting
the feel for it f of G of0 I like to
rewrite it like this F of G of Z
starting from the inside working our way
out so so we say okay when X is zero the
output in our G function is
-1 and that1 now becomes the input in
our F function so if x is ne1 our y
value our output is equal to two and we
solved it two more see if you can try
these four and five G of f of -2 so
again the order is important it's like
working from right to left or if you do
it in this notation that I prefer it's
like from the inside out so we say Okay
F of -2 so -2 is our input our output is
going to be three for our F
function and now we go to our G function
we say if three is the input what's the
output for G oh it's equal to five and
we solved it last example see if you can
do this one F of G of one so again I
like to rewrite it like this F of G of
one and we're putting one into our G
function so when X is one the output for
G is going to be equal to
one now we go to our F function we put
in one so when X is one the output or
the Y value is going to be equal to zero
and we solved it so great job if you
want to learn more about composition of
functions I'll put another video that I
did talking about that right there
follow me over to that video we'll get
some more practice I'll see you there